no one else watches american island here
no not since
like years ago you don't chin you like
music this season the town is
[ __ ] stupid how good people are you
gonna vote
that's like i never vote i've never
voted you just like to watch it yeah i
just checked them out
yeah i just watched those videos like
there was like there was a homeless lady
like a dime piece mom with a little baby
and she was like yeah i'm homeless right
now like hopefully i can make it here
at least those stories always [ __ ]
give me oh dude i'll cry myself
i'll cry sunday nights you know what the
last three sundays i've cried
michael the x factor
uh all those [ __ ] shows when they
bring out those stories oh
dude american idol really knows how to
tug at your heartstrings this one girl
has some uh
like serious disease and she's like yeah
they predict i'm only gonna live to 36.
and she got big uh like her sister
recorder on tick-tock singing
from her like hospital to bed and she
can [ __ ] sing
and her sister goes uh hey this my
sister singing from the hospital bed
if she gets however many yeses shot this
from american idol
and so she got a ton of yeses so she
auditioned for american idol dude
she can sing damn it's crazy
yeah and then there's then there's
another dude there's this big dude whose
father passed away next to him in bed
when he was six and his brother has
um his brother's on the spectrum he has
like the mentality of a nine-year-old
it's heartbreaking and his his brother
kept asking where like every time it's
father's day or his birthday where his
dad's at
and he's like 27 now oh [ __ ] so he wrote
a song about his brother and his brother
yeah i ain't trying to cry you know this
[ __ ] show oh yeah you watch it i'm
telling like god i am american
and they the big guy with the brother
with autism and dad passed away he could
sing but he's only 18
and they're like man we want to pass you
but we're going to do you a favor by
telling you to come back in two years
because you need more work
they're like we don't want to ruin this
for you yeah go do gigs around town
and then come here in two years and it's
gonna be a much better time hopefully he
[ __ ] sticks with it
all the stories man dude the stories are
nuts there's one that this
uh dude got um he was a baby and got
his family got blown up in a bomb and he
survived it but he's
you know got no this american idol no it
was uh i think x factor
x factor one of those shows and uh he
went out there and sang imagine
by uh [ __ ] john lennon dude there's
some of them
dude when they say when they say their
stories i look at my girl my god i hope
they can sing
dear god but when they do doesn't it
[ __ ] you up
mind-blowing dude when they can it's the
only thing that's emotional
so weird oh my god i hope they [ __ ]
make it
yeah it's food or like the homeless lady
like she she was a mom and her
dad yeah her dad came her dad's homeless
she's homeless she has a little kid
the the other her baby daddy just dipped
out on her
and she uh i was telling my girl i'm
like
man if you're uh katy perry she has like
50 million dollars
i just don't see how you just don't be
like hey where you live i'ma buy a house
if you have a kid i have 50 million
dollars
i guess my girl's like what you do that
opens up the floodgates for other people
i'm like
all right it's one time deal you know i
don't know
[Laughter]
you're invested oh i mean it was a show
also like that uh when you write your
songs
and they had uh like uh john legend
uh that [ __ ] gay the police no no not
the voices
that's john that's sean legend and he
helps you write your songs and [ __ ]
it is oh yeah yeah because you're
anastasia shit's weak
[Applause]
yeah you can't you can't do too many of
those shows because
what's crazy is the american idol they
go what song you're singing they're like
oh this is my original song wrote
produce myself
and they're like 15 or 16 and even
like lionel richie's like i mean you're
ridiculous
yeah like you're 16. who are the judges
the judges are katy perry lionel richie
and luke bryant
they're great oh luke bryan the the
country star
i like that guy yeah yeah he's dope i
thought that was chris rick
damn that's crazy i i auditioned for agt
like a couple years ago really yeah
trying to be that clean mainstream
i was like man this ain't for me did you
really yeah
i didn't have like the i didn't have
like the minute you were on the tv not
on the tv
you know did you not pass that did i win
no dude
i'm glad i did it it was in pasadena it
was such a blessing that i didn't yeah
yeah
because i was like bro this is weird and
like they didn't even care about my
jokes
you know it was did you do the two they
want your story yeah yeah
but like but like the thing with these
shows is like
like i'm not sad about my story you know
some people are still going through i'm
not saying these people
you know like i'm not you don't you
don't lean into your story yeah i'm just
different where i'm at with my story
it's just like i'm not sad
yeah i'm not like those are the cards
you're dealt and you powered yeah i
powered through it you know but like
i get you know these other people
they're able to lean into it because
they you know probably still feeling it
probably still going through it
probably you know still working through
those emotions but me it's just
different
so like i felt uncomfortable and i'm so
glad i didn't because i remember
when my uh my manager called me and told
me i didn't make it on agt i was like
[ __ ] yes
and then literally that same night was
when uh because i just had met rogan
and he hit me up he was like hey man i
want you to come do rogan and friends
that's cool so it was like
this is it see ya yeah yeah i was like
see i'm never doing this the big bang
upstairs right yeah you know this thing
for you yeah
it was it was weird it's weird for you
like american idol like
obviously it gives you like a fan base
but it's tricky because then you're
under their contract
it's like the ultimate fighter it's like
it's much better to get on the ultra
not do the ultimate fire make the ufc
the right the regular way then the
ultimate fighter because you get an
ultimate fighter
you're tied in these long contracts
you're not getting paid well
yeah so same thing with american idol
like they own all your [ __ ] dude
like carrie underwood didn't start make
money until she got out of that contract
dude i wonder how [ __ ] long that
contract is oh it's a
beast really yeah they tie you up
you know only a couple of people like
that uh
that have won it have actually like
popped yeah jim kelly
kelly kelly clarkson's has made for
different reasons though but yeah kelly
clarkson
carried under did jennifer hudson win no
she got 10. she got oh she had 10. she
had 10.
really what about jordan sparks did she
does she want it
she won she is she pop she's from she's
from arizona yep yeah
jordan sparks still killing it yeah yeah
she stays straight uh she's more so a
mom now
she concentrates more so on her family
yeah coming up
she got a tv show coming out she had
that song one step at a time
oh yeah no air with chris brown scotty
mccrary had a big
uh splash in country music but most of
them don't do well like tyler
taylor hicks is changing tires yeah what
about that one guy
uh david cook works at uh [ __ ] it was
a mormon guy
mormon david archuleta oh dave archuleta
had that one really big song crush
that's all he had did he win uh i
believe
he won he did like a short episode on
hannah montana and then
i haven't really i don't want that yeah
that guy oh yeah i'm really kidding
that kid yeah he was really good he was
the runner up yeah
runner up got him jesus chris look at me
fans he had dude over 97 million people
voted
what the [ __ ] but he didn't win now he's
the right
he's the runner up second place yeah
again so who beat him
but it's weird because they get done in
you know 96 because obviously 97 million
people didn't buy a single otherwise
he'd be
yeah i wonder why i wonder if it's just
like oh they only like you for this
you know what i mean they don't really
give you something they don't extend
other [ __ ] yeah
i mean i get it carrie underwood you
know what i mean undeniably undeniable
yeah
clarkson jennifer hudson like you you
get it but like some people i wonder if
it's just like oh i just like you
here on this like i don't give a [ __ ]
about your music after that
i wonder if that's the case well does it
go with like i like your story more than
your talent
that uh that could be a thing too is
that him singing there too i think so
let's see
yeah he better still kill it requested a
lot
what you think chad i can tell he's
really good
you know he's singing over at other
songs so it's a little it's because it's
tough i'd rather him do like an
instrumental thing but you see his his
roles
yeah yeah up and down that's good
you never want to audition for anything
like that i did audition oh you did
audition for
star search
come on down
but you didn't make star search i justin
timberly got it started
self sabotage that's what i did i was so
i was so cocky and overconfident about
my singing at the time
i came in i partied with my friends the
night before oh wow
i was still drunk when i show up to
auditions
oh [ __ ] and i just forgot my lyrics and
then i'm like
so they have a red light on the camera
right yeah they tell you ahead of time
like
millions millions of people are
potentially going to watch this right so
just
make sure you do you well so i'm just
looking at the camera and it's red and
i'm like
i forgot everything and then i'm
thinking like oh [ __ ] they're going to
play this like they do american idol all
the [ __ ] ups oh
yeah you'd be the [ __ ] luckily they
no it's out there somewhere if someone
has it in star search chin's all
no just singing
usher or drew hill nice and slow
something like tell me what you want
you can't remember i can't remember how
old were you at the time um
mid-twenties you look like a swamp yeah
you've been cocky mid-twenties
yeah yeah oh my god i thought it was bad
man
damn damn and then it's a good learning
lesson did you call your parents you're
like yeah i [ __ ] up my parents have no
idea what they're back home to the
family and [ __ ]
no i bet you talking cash [ __ ] before
they end yeah yeah yeah
star circus different after this oh
they're still sure yeah they saw all the
other contestants
all the other auditions and i'm like i'm
like dude i got this
after hearing everyone's scene and i
came up and i'm like sorry
i see the red light and then i'm like i
forget my letters i'm like [ __ ] which is
so
weird because you will definitely learn
from it because now you're like
over yeah yeah yeah yeah over like oh
you're a little worried right now like
you're super prepared i am but that's
for a producer that's probably one of
the better things you want to yeah yeah
just
constantly looking at it like ah that
moment prepared you for right now i'm
serious i think everything prepares you
for
what you do damn and you know who was
the host back then
i remember let me see the reboot of star
street you know my manager
uh is ed mcmahon's son lex mcmahon oh
yeah
oh yeah
certainly star search was big dude they
found so many people
uh bo weaver and sam riddle okay i don't
know
no that's that's uh narrated so it was
arsenio hall maybe
yes i think it was arsenio yeah yeah i
think it was our senior deal man
oh he's alleged did you get to meet him
no no oh oh he didn't cover i mean i
didn't
pass the audience you met him at the
store no i haven't met him but i
always say i would always see him still
a beast yeah
how about that when i get off stage with
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son